[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsey show it's a show about your work
it's a show about your money it's a show
about your relationships your life and
you we're going to talk about you right
in front of you
ken coleman is with me as my co-host
today here on the air as we'll be
particularly taking your calls about
work because that's what ken takes every
day on the ken coleman show his best
selling book
from paycheck to purpose is out there to
help you do just that welcome back ken
good to be back happy new year your
first time on the show this year yeah
yeah fun times always good to be back
and it's book launch week i'm pumped
well you should be i haven't you've been
excited about a book launch no i'm
kidding
well dave everybody knows i'm always
excited about your book launches ken
yeah but it's your book launch this is
my i haven't done a book launch in eight
years so it's time for me to be excited
how does this feel tomorrow comes out
tomorrow so midnight tonight amazon will
start their masterful santa claus like
shipping that they do and uh ramsey
solutions uh shipping team will do the
same so those of you that have bought
baby steps millionaires it is on the way
baby and that means you got just a few
more hours to buy it and get the all the
pre-sale stuff included and get the book
for 20 and the audiobook and the e-book
and the audiobook of legacy journey and
the e-book and so forth and so on and
man it's fun it should be it should be
been a long time yeah i got a 16 hour
day ahead of me tomorrow with media and
uh back working like a like i need to or
something and uh it's good man it's good
i'm enjoying it and so looking forward
to being on the air and talking about
this idea of hope because there's just
been too many people out there stealing
people hope that's true hope stealers
man they're like dream killers
cousins of dream killers they're
hopeless dealers the timing of this book
is so fantastic because here we come you
know some people think we've been in a
pandemic for two years some for a year
we're not going to get into that but the
point is is it changed everybody's view
of the future
and here comes a book that's proven
decades of proof
that you can
win with money you can be a millionaire
without inheriting it there is a process
a clear path and i think more and more
people want to take control of their own
lives they realize the federal
government's not going to make them rich
i'm going to take care of them i just
think it's perfect timing for this it's
exciting to see really a whole new
generation grab this information i'm i'm
jacked about it i mean it's a lot of
things i have said before but put
together in a way i've never said i've
done put it together before and when you
finish reading the book or you're broke
brother-in-law with a negative opinion
about money finishes reading the book it
makes the case
so airtight that you
can start from nothing in america and
become a millionaire it's airtight
it's airtight you can do it i i know you
can do it because i've shown tens of
thousands of people how to become
millionaires we've got baby step
millionaires everywhere that's one of
the things that inspired me to do this i
thought you know what this stuff's
working we ought to tell somebody
and uh it is working
it's very very real and i just can't
stand these people they're so i mean
social media has just become a black
hole of stupid
and it's just like everything you open
up on there is just some ninny some
negative some lie
something
it's just hate filled everywhere and um
it doesn't matter what you do it's
filled with hate and so
i i'm just saying you know what
no yeah
good for you can actually become a
millionaire
and i can show you how well maybe maybe
you shouldn't be rich well that's not a
discussion of a moral construct we can
have that discussion otherwise
but um
it's can you get a million dollars
legally
within a reasonable period of time
to provide a the first step of stability
to your family and your family tree the
first step in you being able to give
outrageously a million is not a billion
but it's more than most people got
and so it's something to aim at as your
first big wealth building milestone and
we're going to show people it can be
done yeah and it is great by the way the
book cover is fantastic i got to know
inquiring mine's one of those you got a
lot of people going to get this book in
the mail
did you is that really early morning
sunshine on the on your head there on
your left shoulder did you put that in
there did you get angelic yeah of course
i have a hair of course i have a glow
coming off of my head because when i
first saw it dave i was quiet long
enough to see if i could hear oh yeah
yeah really there's and yeah you can see
the halo you got up early for that i
think yeah it was it was sunrise on my
farm there it is we went out to my farm
at sunrise i've got a bunch of black
fence out there too and we shot some
leaning up on the black fence you know
the obligatory look that didn't just
look like a oompa loompa leaning on a
fence but um
uh but yeah we
shot you know how you doing photo shoot
is like 500 pictures you enjoy the
process most of them suck oh i hate it
but but i was on the farm at sunrise
which isn't a bad thing and that's
that's gorgeous that's that's how they
got me out there that's that was the
bribe and so i got to be on my farm and
hang out and um
you know that's one of the things i like
is just having a big old piece of dirt
like that that just holds the earth
together and and i need to own a piece
of it and that's it's one of my favorite
happy places is being out on the farm so
that was perfect for me but yeah i just
needed maybe a little piece of grass
hanging out of my mouth full hay seed
you know full hillbilly and you needed
some i'm sure he's too late to do this
but uh because the audiobook is done but
some ambient noises some crickets in the
background maybe a little brook sound of
a brook behind you a cow
yeah the occasional off in the distance
that's it yeah no it's maybe not maybe
not but that's not everybody's picture
of a millionaire right but it's just me
hanging out and it's uh that's kind of
you know like real world today that's
how i dress every day that's it i don't
know on the same shirt today thank god
that would be weird wouldn't it but um
it's a wonder because i don't really
look at my clothes that closely i should
it upsets the media people but yeah so
baby steps millionaire
today's the last day to get it on
pre-sale if you order it right now at
ramseysolutions.com
you can get all the goodies that go with
it about 100 worth of stuff if you wait
till tomorrow the price goes up and all
the goodies disappear
and so all the extra add-ons and and
things you can enjoy with it and um hey
thanks to a couple of you posted on
amazon i flipped over there to see what
it was doing on sales and apparently we
had some kind of a quality control issue
with the audio book and one of the uh
chapters laid over the other chapter so
i was talking to myself twice on one
section and it was you couldn't
understand it and so we figured it out a
couple people posted about it thanks for
letting us know we fixed it and it's all
all ready to go now and so the
audiobooks rocking as well but a lot of
people with audio books nowadays
we're seeing those numbers across
through the roof yeah it's amazing
because people are commuting because the
the spawn of podcasting the popularity
of podcast is make audio books more
popular yeah makes a lot of sense well
and audiobooks are are honestly uh this
is a podcast that we're doing right now
and a radio show that we're doing right
now and so audiobooks are actually more
thought out oh yeah oh yeah yes yeah
it's actually then the average podcast
some of these podcasts i tune into them
like yeah you guys just kind of sat down
and started talking didn't you yeah you
know that's what they do yeah no
forethought at all so no game plan at
all so
do check us out folks we appreciate you
being there and we appreciate the number
of you that have already bought the book
it's uh sold um
about 100 000 copies already before we
even started and so thank you it's a
best seller i'm sure as a result but you
guys do that for us and we appreciate
you and uh here's the thing
if you want to believe or you know
somebody that needs to believe
that starting from nothing you can still
actually build wealth in america today
i make an airtight case
you can't walk away from this evidence
stories
actual arithmetic
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in the back of the book
don't miss it it's called baby steps
millionaires it comes out tomorrow and
if you pre-order today at
ramseysolutions.com
you get the best deal ever this is the
ramsey chef
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your work
your money your relationships and you
right here on the ramsey show dennis is
in new york city hi dennis how are you
good
hi dave and ken
um so my question is
i have a union pension right which will
give me 50 of my base salary when i
retire
currently i have 400 000 in my 401k
um
and i'm just wondering
so i'm running through the baby steps
once i get my
uh emergency fund if i should just
attack the mortgage instead of starting
up the 401k again
no i'd start it up
put 15 in there that's something you can
control you're doing really well though
i mean goodness gracious you're in great
shape how much do you own your mortgage
uh about 220. okay what's your household
income
uh
this year is just under 200. okay so we
put 30 000 or so into 401ks uh and uh
roth iras and so forth and then we
attack the mortgage with the rest of it
you'll probably don't be done with the
mortgage in under five years how old are
you
38. oh wow yeah you'll be great you'll
be in good shape
what you're going to want to do then
when you get to baby step 7 is you may
actually crank back on the 401k at that
point and start doing some side
investing we call it bridge investing
money you can get to before you're 59
and a half some mutual funds or some
paid for real estate or something like
that that you can get to because you're
not going to touch your pension or your
well i don't know how your pension's set
up but um you may you may be able to
touch it because you may have had 20
years in or something but um yeah it
wouldn't hurt to have some extra money
that's non-retirement saved
as well
as we go along linda is in charlotte hi
linda welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon it's an honor to talk
with you you too what's up
um i have questions i'm going to be 68
this summer my husband is 61 we're both
going to retire the end of march
i have two mortgages oh thank you two
mortgages uh my own buy or i have a
house worth 580 000
i owe 199 000 on it i have a home in
florida worth 480 000 and i have 59 000
on it
my plan to be debt-free when we retire
is to sell north carolina
and pay that small loan off in florida
my question is we have family in ohio
should we buy a small place in ohio a
piece of real estate that we can go back
and forth with or should we take
the profit from north carolina
and invest it
okay so you're going to have the florida
house is going to be your main place
when you sell the charlotte house yes
yes
um
how much you got in your investment
accounts
my retirement my husband and i's we have
about eight hundred thousand dollars way
to go
way to go
millionaires you did it
yes proud of you our net worth is 1.8
with a property
very good i have a quick question dave i
don't know if it'll inform your your
opinion here who is the family in ohio
who are the family members
um my granddaughter will be in her
senior year i'd like to go to her cross
country events
um i have two sons in in ohio my
daughter lives here in north carolina
okay
the ohio property would be for the two
sons to see them
yes my granddaughter
okay what would you spend on that
under 300 000.
and pay cash of course
cash yes
yeah get a little condo or something
that'd be all right
i did that i bought a condo in knoxville
when my kids were in college there just
to have a place to hang out we didn't
use it enough really to justify it and
you probably won't use this enough to
justify it but your stuff is there and
your clothes are there and you don't
even have to pack a suitcase you can
just throw some stuff in a backpack and
go
because you got enough stuff there to
live on
when you go in to see the grandkids and
you don't have to worry about hotels or
debit cards or anything else or
availability or dealing with you know
vrbo or yeah all that kind of stuff you
just move in and you've got the money i
really wouldn't spend much more than
that just get a little condo something
you don't have any maintenance trouble
with
let someone else do the maintenance on
it put you know furnish it reasonably
where you can enjoy it when you're there
and then do stock it with personal items
and with uh clothing so you don't have
to
haul that back and forth it took me a
while with our second homes to learn to
do that
okay we always took a suitcase like we
were going to somebody else's house
which is stupid i mean you got enough
old clothes and stuff to put around
there and enough you know just make sure
you got your own
everything in there so you don't
duplicate everything so you don't have
to uh do that phone chargers all that
kind of stuff you just don't have to
think about it that way you're not quote
packing to go on a trip you're just
switching houses
and right okay so my social security
take-home will be a little over 2 000.
living in florida alone we could
probably live on that 2000
because we are very frugal and um i
would my other question i wouldn't i
would spend more than that well
well how do i know how much i can take
out of my investment oh i don't think
you're going to take too much out it's
not in your being
okay i mean if you make eight hundred
thousand i mean if you've got a thousand
it makes ten percent that's 80 grand so
you pull out 50 grand
additional and you're not going to pull
that much out i probably can't get you
to do it
so another copy another couple around 2
000 a month yeah another couple two or
three thousand out of that and that
thing will run forever and ever and ever
and ever
and don't worry about it i mean just
but you know don't take out ten thousand
a month if you do you're gonna start
chewing into that principle
so um
but somehow i don't think that's on her
list yeah i i don't hear any uh
flags classic millionaires classic
millionaire everyday millionaires we
call them with chris hogan's book but
they're people that um i don't know that
she necessarily followed the baby steps
so i really can't call her a babysitter
millionaire but everyday millionaires
these people started with nothing and
hera did nothing and uh saved and got
their house paid off and she's got a
millionaire net worth they're everywhere
ken yeah they're everywhere they're all
over america
and they defy you
uh people with a political agenda you
hope steelers that say that america is
dead and the ability to build wealth in
america and have a good life and take
control of your own life and those kinds
of things
uh they defy
your your your stupid words people her
very life defies that yeah and so it's
beautiful wonderful one encouragement
linda
you you have lived well
you're you you and your husband are men
and women of character you've been smart
you are frugal
um i i like taking dave's advice here
and not take ten thousand a month but
take more than the two thousand a month
and enjoy that time with the grandkids
and your kids you you've earned this and
so there's a there's a it doesn't have
to be that tight
start doing some uh outrageous
generosity yeah live something you need
to carry an extra thousand dollars in
your pocket at all times just in case
you see something that needs to happen
in the world and you can make it happen
random acts of kindness and those kinds
of things and you're in a position to do
that you live like no one else so that
later you can live and give
like no one else now i don't suggest
people impulse a hundred thousand dollar
gift no but a thousand dollar gift when
you got a millionaid is a good impulse
you know rachel has really resonated
with our audience with something she
says over and over again and she's
talking about giving people permission
to spend that's what we talk about with
the budget and i think linda if you guys
put a really good budget together use
our every dollar budget and put a
retirement budget together and go wait a
second i have permission to spend it's
got some room in it for yes a nice
restaurant yes you know it's got some
room in it for whatever and two thousand
bucks in florida doesn't have that so
you need to loosen up it loosely
the old purse strings there a little bit
and have a little enjoyment enjoying
money
without overdoing it is a sign of
maturity yeah and it's not age maturity
it's emotional maturity
but a lot of people like her and uh or
they've been through what we've been
through
sharon has that tendency when you go
broke to not
ever spend again yeah just gonna hold on
tightly and just be super frugal and
that'll get you to a certain point but
you're also also supposed to enjoy money
now some of you that overspend out there
you spend like you're in congress you
don't have any issue with this enjoying
money thing you enjoy other people's
money called debt
uh you enjoy everything that's not we're
not talking to you we're talking to the
frugal who need to be more generous and
enjoy their money you need to and you
need to do all of those things at the
same time and it's very possible to do
it all
this
is the ramsey shadow
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america right
here in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage eric and alyssa are
with us hey guys how are you doing great
welcome where do you guys live we are
from gilbert arizona oh fun fun the
phoenix area yes just outside of phoenix
wonderful good to have you guys all the
way to nashville to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off dave
we paid off a hundred and sixteen
thousand dollars all right how long did
that take a little over eight years wow
all right and your range of income
during that time 57 000 to about 130
000. nice jump what do y'all do for a
living
i stay home and take care of these three
kiddos over here and i was in ministry
for a long time but i started my own
business at the beginning of 2021. wow
good timing yes what do you do what kind
of a business i run a communications
business so i do a lot of freelance
writing editing uh digital strategy
those sorts of things that's a good move
for somebody from the pastorate from the
ministry very nice yeah what was your
position words
i was a youth minister oh okay good very
good well congratulations you guys all
right so the vast majority of this time
you made 57. uh in there 57 to about 75
yeah you know then the jump came when
you you know the big jump came when you
started the business yes definitely
correct very cool so what kind of debt
was the hundred and sixteen thousand
dave we paid off our house
looking at weird people
i love it what's this house worth uh
about 500 000 you know phoenix market's
a little volatile but you know it's
about 500 000 very nice very nice very
cool so what was what church were you
youth pastor in uh at st patrick's
church in scottsdale arizona okay very
good good very cool man what made you
guys decide to take this journey eight
years ago well it started a little
before that even we were both working in
youth ministry back in 2008 and i was
making a whopping 35 000 and he was
making less than 30. and i had started
dating this guy and i knew he had no
debt and he had a savings account which
like blew my mind because we worked in
ministry
so i walked into a co-worker um trish's
office and she had the total money
makeover on her bookshelf and i was
going on a flight i was like hey can i
borrow that book she's like sure i've
never read it i was like great
so i grabbed it
and i didn't even know how much debt i
personally had at this time come to find
out i had 27 000 worth of debt and i
tore through the book and as soon as i
was done with the book i was like i need
to get rid of this debt so over the next
two years um we finally got engaged and
then married but over those two years i
was able to turn through that twenty
seven thousand dollars of debt wow and
then we got married
um and joined our life together debt
free and we went on an all-inclusive
trip to costa rica for
and i had kept telling him we need to
budget we need to budget we need to
budget he's like why budget
i take care of my money just fine
so so dave i'm uh maybe ashamed and
excited to say that i actually read
total money makeover on my honeymoon
sitting poolside in costa rica
with a pina colada in my hand
there's so much wrong with this picture
from people oh they're probably like
this poor couple has no money oh they're
too broke to be here
reading that dave book they must not
have any money i love it and that begins
everything that we gain everything we
got home we did our first budget a
couple days after our honeymoon it took
us about six hours to do our first
budget of course but we nailed through
it and our big goal at the time was to
buy
put as much down as possible on a house
we wanted to do at least 20 percent but
we thought if we could get to 40 or 50
percent we'd be in good shape we ended
up doing about 40 percent uh down on our
house about a year and a half later we
used one of your elps named ed serchick
in the phoenix area who's fantastic and
um and that just started the the ball
rolling and um we um
we we did a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
and then um as excited as it was we were
doing everything right we did have some
storms come into our life yeah in 2013
we had one child and then
we found out we were newly expecting our
second and we were thrilled and over the
moon again we're doing everything right
no debt no nothing and about 15 weeks
into the pregnancy we realized something
was very wrong with me and something was
also very wrong with our baby um and so
at 18 weeks i delivered our son gabriel
joseph and um and i nearly died as well
during it
so here we are grieving the loss of a
child
and then two months later we lose eric's
aunt who passed away very unexpectedly
and like three days after he comes back
from the funeral
we find out um he no longer has a job so
he is out of we're grieving a loss
losing family members we have no income
and then
eric just starts to grind um he is going
to our church every day to pray for an
hour in the morning then he's going to
the library to do freelance work to look
for jobs
at one point he flower shops they pay
for delivery drivers
he went to a local fellow shop and he
knew he could get paid five dollars per
delivery and if he did six an hour
that's 30 bucks an hour so he delivered
flowers for valentine's day for three
days and that paid for our groceries
that month
and then we sold gold jewelry that like
nothing sentimentals like kitchen stuff
around you know we just sold anything
and then as he's at the library every
day i got the mail one day and i have a
letter and it says all of our insurance
claims for the delivery and loss of our
son were denied so we have 43 000 in
medical bills that we are on the hook
for now we have no job
it was it was horrible so but the good
news was a couple months later ended up
getting a job there was actually higher
paying than the previous one which is
excellent and when these medical bills
came in you know you have a book that
you recommend called the go getter um
and i'd read that book and
and so that book um they talk all about
how um this it's a fable and this guy
goes and he he just grinds and he runs
in all these obstacles but he just keeps
going because he's just trying to
achieve this thing and so um i had read
that too and so i got on the phone with
every single medical provider we had
tons of bills and if it was ten ten
about ten dollars or ten thousand
dollars dave we called them all up and i
negotiated every single one um and every
single one of them was able to give us
some kind of a sometimes it was ten
percent sometimes it was forty percent
but we knocked off all that medical debt
and thankfully we had some savings
emergency fund things like that that we
knew we could tap into if we needed to
and we were able to pay those medical
bills off without actually we don't even
consider it part of our debt
because we never even actually had to
use our emergency fund and never even
had to take unemployment um and so much
of that is a testament to this to this
program well real quick because i want
people to hear this this this massive
storm happens after the commitment
to
to do a 15-year mortgage to pay it off
never have debt serious budgeting i just
have to believe what would you say to
people
the power of the budget and the power of
the discipline before the storm helped
you not panic in the storm is that true
the the but having a plan in front of
our in front of us that we knew we could
execute and the fact that we'd already
been doing it together for several years
um gave us the confidence to know that
we can make it through that storm it was
a true cornerstone of our marriage faith
finances our relationship that's that's
what let's be honest our family's built
on yeah
you guys are amazing and and you know
there's just a whole many different ways
you can react to a crisis and uh this
guy's buffalo man he runs right straight
in the storm yeah i was thinking instead
of getting scared you got busy yeah you
didn't really have time to because he
got scared so he got busy but yeah right
right there wasn't much time to focus on
fear after you started doing everything
you were doing you know i was driving
home exactly i was driving home on my
last time doing one of those flower
deliveries at valentine's day and here i
was i was working a great job that i
loved and tears were filling up my eyes
for two reasons one i was sad because i
was doing this and i was like i just
don't want to do this isn't what a man
should be doing and at the same time
tears of joy because i knew i was doing
it for my wife and at the time exactly
what a man should be doing way to go
dude all right get the kiddos in what
are their names and ages
helen who is nine nolan is six and clara
joy is four all right
i love it
all right eric and alyssa and the team
phoenix arizona we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you and a copy of
total money makeover for you you're
going to be baby steps millionaires
before you know it house and everything
are paid off they're weird people
116 000 paid off in eight years what a
story making 57 to 130. count it down
let's hear a debt-free screen ready
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
the house is paid for
how weird does it feel to be that young
and not have a payment in the world
oh
love it this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it is book launch week for the baby
steps millionaire's book it officially
hits the street tomorrow and you can get
it this thursday night george campbell
rachel cruz and i will be doing a live
event called building wealth in 2022
now we're not going to be able to see
you in person because there were only 1
600 tickets and they sold in about a
half a second
and live events these days are really
popular but guess what we are going to
live stream this event completely free
live on thursday night this coming
thursday january the 13th and you can
watch it free over a hundred thousand
people have already signed up to watch
the live stream in addition to the 1600
in the room gonna be a big
deal building wealth does that sound
kind of fun building wealth in 2022 yeah
it does sound fun we're going to walk
you through exactly how to do it for
real and the things to watch for the
signs to watch for when you're about to
get uh
messed up you're about to get screwed
over you're about to step in a trap of
your own making now we can show you that
as well ramsey solutions dot com slash
wealth to register you do have to
register but it is free
building wealth in 2022 ramsey solutions
dot com
slash
wealth
don't miss out
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money benjamin is in knoxville
hey benjamin welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken thanks for having me sure
man what's up
um well
i'm my wife and i are actually getting
real close to hitting that millionaire
mark and um
well our first question which it kind of
sounds like i need to be on the live
stream thursday is
what do we do with the extra money now
that we've paid everything off um and
then the other one more is
i
sort of like my job but i don't have a
lot of control over it and i was wanting
to kind of figure out how to get
a direction to go into business for
myself
and do that with a good plan to get more
control and fulfillment so
all right so uh let's let's take the
idea creation question on here so how do
we come up with ideas for somebody like
you who wants to work for himself the
first thing is is the context that you
have to begin to look for
business possibilities within these two
questions what problem do i want to
solve or what desire do i want to
fulfill so businesses benjamin at the
end of the day they either solve a
problem through a product or service or
they fulfill a desire so this simple
example of solving a problem
fixing networking or technology issues
okay or
selling shoes or
making
women feel beautiful with makeup if a
woman wants to start a business and hair
or makeup or whatever so one is solving
a problem the other is
meeting a desire or fulfilling a desire
so we start with that premise and so you
need to ask yourself who are the people
i most want to help when you allow
yourself just to think and you have to
take yourself to a place where i don't
have to work for anybody else and if i
was paying myself
what problems would i want to solve
or what
desires would i want to fulfill and you
begin to attach that to people and so
you have history in your life you have
experience and environment
in your adult life and begin to think of
those types of people and problems or
desires and then when you get there you
go okay what are the solutions to those
problems or solutions to those desires
that i connect with this is about the
ideation part and and then benjamin once
you begin to see that you okay what
would business look like then you have
to do more research so those are just
the idea phase and i'm quickly walking
you through a framework that will allow
you to begin to not just generate ideas
but then test the idea so then you look
at okay
what what are viable business models
that other people have done we want to
see is there a track record here
and then you want to look at talent what
you do best because as an entrepreneur
at some point when you launch this thing
you're the chief everything officers
dave has said so many times at our
entree leadership events and so
initially you're going to be doing a lot
of things yourself so you want to
mitigate uh you doing as much of a much
of excuse me as little as possible
things that you're awful at so as the
entrepreneur even as the chief
everything officer you're going to think
about who am i going to have to pay to
help me launch this to do things that
quite frankly i suck at because i only
want to focus on things that i'm decent
at average at or better as i launch this
so that's just a quick little framework
for you as you come up with ideas and
then begin to vet the
ideas you had something already pop into
your mind hadn't you for sure
well yes and no so the problem is i'm in
sales right now so i'm good at
increasing top line i've been in
engineering and i'm good at making
things run better and the problem is
every business does that so i don't
really know
what business to attach to
what problems do you get excited about
solving
you personally in a business framework
um it's probably
making the deals and bringing in top
line
yeah the art of the deal yeah that's
good okay so marketing so what product
or service could you personally get
extra excited about selling see you're
already a good sales guy i mean you love
the art of the deal you love closing the
deal bringing a solution to somebody but
now you personalize this what would you
get absolutely rabid excited about
selling if you don't know i really like
cars and motorcycles and stuff so all
right might have something to attach
with that all right now we're getting
some clues here and we're an engineer
yeah maybe you uh do you know open a
custom
it shop work
yeah that could work
and because there's probably a few guys
around knoxville and turn a wrench and
help you with that
and uh you can you could do some design
work and bring in the business both
close the deal and each one of those
deals are higher end ticket items those
aren't a custom shop
for motorcycles or for auto
you know uh you know whether it's frame
up custom or redos or whatever i mean
there's a whole different world there
that's
uh money wise that is um per per unit of
sale would be ridiculous yeah
potentially but um but you know you'd be
using your engineering hat to uh work on
the some of the design
uh maybe even some of the implementation
but certainly on the sale yeah and i
just made that up i have no idea well i
don't know what else you do with cars
off the top of my head yeah but that's
actually the exercise dave right there
you take an idea and you go okay what
are real lines of revenue not
fantasyland like real businesses so the
next step is he's going to go meet
somebody who's in that business and go
hey could i is there a mutual connection
where you could get a phone call or a
cup of coffee and go hey talk to me
about the business give me the highs
give me the lows what's the margin is it
a high margin how volatile is it because
some of that stuff can be volatile but
it can also be very high margin very
cool good stuff man thanks benjamin
congratulations on everyday millionaire
status
ah trevor's with us in louisville
kentucky hi trevor welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so my wife and i are in babysit 3d and
we're saving up 20 towards our down
payment for our house good so my
question is more out of curiosity
why is the zero percent home
0 down home mortgage a bad idea
well there are only two uh there is the
va loan which is a more expensive loan
is why it's a bad idea uh the interest
rate's slightly higher and the funding
fees and so forth on the front end are
higher um and so it's just not a it's
just not a good loan
uh the second one is a first-time
homebuyer loan of some kind that has
nothing down and most of those have
restrictions on them on resale or
recouping upon resale or something else
and so
the vast majority of the time you're
giving up something for the fact that
you're not putting a down payment in
uh and thirdly i would just add that um
there's something about you doing a deal
where you're putting a down payment that
you're just making a wiser choice you
don't feel as
it's just easy to spend other people's
easier to spend other people's money
called borrowing than it is to spend
your own
uh kind of juxtapose it trevor all the
way over to say what if you saved up an
uh 200 000
and you're going to pay cash
you make a different purchase
when you spend 200 000 out of your
savings account because the way your
brain works because there's pain
involved in that that hurts it's like ah
i just cleaned out 200 grand
yeah so you get real careful about your
purchase real wise about your purchase
versus nothing down doesn't cost me
anything i'm just signing and you get
almost flippant and you almost impulse
all the way over on the other side of
the spectrum into it when you're
spending other people's money and the
down payment or the large down payments
in between those two things it at least
makes you concentrate because you got
skin in the game yeah and you're getting
ahead financially let's not forget that
the whole idea is we're trying to get
out of debt and when you take on a
mortgage on a 15 year you still have a
game plan to knock it out and be
debt-free house and everything very soon
anyway that's what you do
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show
make sure you visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice it's the ramsey show thanks for
being with us america i have no idea
what i'm doing here but i'm going to
wander through this hour ken coleman my
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your work we talk about
your money we talk about your
relationships we talk about your
life
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five dylan is with
us in green bay wisconsin hi dylan
welcome to the ramsey show
hey good afternoon dave and ken how you
guys doing better than we deserve
brother what's up
hey dave i hope you know what you're
talking about because we're coming to
you for some papa dave advice
well i'm an expert on my opinion brother
so
my wife and i are
i would call it having a healthy
disagreement on whether or not
we should be investing in a financial
advisor right now
okay
you have any
financial
uh yeah we do uh right now
run baby steps four five and six good
we've got about 250 000 in retirement
investments okay what would be wrong
with having a smart vester pro in your
corner
well
now the argument um
from my wife is
we've gotten to this point where and
she's having a hard time
committing to paying somebody else to
um you know walk alongside us so to
speak yeah okay
well i when i was broke and uh didn't
have a whole lot to worry about i could
do a will with an online wheel company
when i've got several hundred million
dollars i need a lawyer
the scale means you need
greater areas of expertise
okay
if you want if you want to tinker under
the hood on a 250 000
lamborghini you probably shouldn't do
that unless you're certified to do that
but if you want to turn a wrench on on
your thousand dollar beater go ahead
good luck no problems
you're you're more dealing with a
lamborghini now you need somebody to
walk beside you now you don't need to
pay them a ton uh smart vista pros get
paid based on the balance if you're
doing a managed account or they get paid
based on what you buy either one is okay
but i have a smartvestor pro in my
corner and everybody asks my opinion but
when i get ready to investing or sharon
gets ready you know we're getting ready
to change some of our investments around
sharon's involved uh the smartvestor
pros there and we talk it through we go
okay what are we going to do and why are
we doing this and uh they're not there
to tell us what to do they tell us what
we could do and why and we learn a
little bit from them about what's
happening in the market what's happening
with that particular fund
and the knowledge base that they have
that we don't have because they're in it
every day we learn from and then based
on that we make our own decisions so the
fact that you stand on your own make
your own decisions from before you keep
that part but you just get an advisor in
your corner to give to teach you
yeah you do need that
dylan is it that she's cheap and tight
and doesn't want to pay someone or are
there some fears
underneath this
resistance
uh no i don't think um
basically we're so focused on trying to
get the mortgage out of our lives that
we're we're trying to do everything we
can to
you know become completely debt free and
good
so it's the money if there's no fears
you don't think there's any fear on her
behalf fear of the unknown of working
with a financial pro you think it's just
she's watching every nickel and doesn't
want to pay a professional something you
think that's the core issue
i i think so it's i think she
is comfortable with
how we're managing our investments and
where we're at in our financial journey
right now that she's just
having a hard time saying okay let's
let's pay uh you know the extra money
for somebody well i wouldn't pay
somebody a flat fee you don't need to at
this stage but i would meet with a
smartvestor pro and let them get paid on
the accounts they manage for you they'll
give you advice on the rest of them
and um here's the thing
if what she's saying is i don't want
people telling me how to handle my money
i agree
i agree with her but what i do want
people to do is to teach me some things
i don't know before i handle my money
and that's what your advisor should be
doing that's why we always say you need
one with the heart of a teacher not the
heart of a salesman
i do not want people to turn over their
money to someone called a wealth manager
and walk away and hope they do a good
job and pay them eight thousand dollars
a year to do it or something no no no no
no no no not at all i don't know we are
going to raise our own kids
and you're going to handle your own
money but you've got an advisor in your
corner and the bible says in the
multitude of counsel
there is safety
and so i've got to have people that know
how to do things that i don't know how
to do and have knowledge bases that i
don't know about to go places i've never
been before two things i'll give you
dylan to help with this conversation
number one a conversation doesn't equal
commitment so sit down with several
smartvestor pros that's what we tell you
to do and sit down with her and help her
understand a conversation with a pro
doesn't mean a commitment secondly in
that conversation i think clarity on how
it works will give her confidence to
move forward now the clarity is this is
a person to teach us not to tell us
that's correct we don't need people
instructing us what to do
we don't need people taking over for us
we're perfectly capable
um i do agree with that and i and you
could probably get by i will tell you 78
of the millionaires that we did the
millionaire study uh use an investment
advisor
so there's a correlation between being a
millionaire and using an investment
advisor
you can call it causal or not causal but
it's there there's a correlation ricardo
is with us in sacramento hi ricardo
welcome to the ramsey show
hey there dave and team how are you guys
doing great man what's up
hey so i am 24 i am currently on baby
step four
i quit my job which was my first job
after graduating college i just really
needed to leave that work environment
but i don't have anything lined up
i'm job searching right now and i'm come
across two pathways i found a job that's
very rewarding but they're going to work
me like a dog
it's a 70 hour work week
but like i said it's very rewarding and
overall the compensation is okay and the
other job
involves a lot a lot of commuting but
the pay is roughly the same which
way do you think i should go well
definitely not the second one because
that comedian's going to wear you out in
about a week
uh the question is the the job that's
going to work you 70 hours is very
rewarding can you find that somewhere
else and how long will the 70 hours last
is that a indefinite situation
yeah that's an indefinite situation you
married
i am not married
you won't be yeah i was gonna say i was
gonna say you could do it for a short
term but even single 70 hours a week
man's not woman's not created to work
like that and that's gonna eventually
take its toll if it had a huge financial
upside and it got you out of debt but
you're in baby step four i would pass
uh i love that you found something
that's rewarding so what i would do
ricardo's i would focus on what about it
feels rewarding to you now i'm gonna go
look for that in this economy be patient
young man you're in great financial
shape
don't
sell out for something that just looks
good it's got to be good in all
aspects hold on we're going to send you
a copy of ken's new book from paycheck
to purpose it's a bestseller you will
love reading it it'll help you with this
exact
process
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their 30
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 it is book launch week here at
ramsey
and uh something i've not said for about
eight years i have a new book out uh
that'll happen tomorrow it comes out
it's called baby steps millionaires
and uh it is the proven process to show
you how to become a millionaire how tens
of thousands have the actual byline is
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too
and we invite you to get a copy today at
ramseysolutions.com that way you get all
kinds of goodies thrown in about a
hundred dollars worth of stuff uh the
e-book the audiobook the legacy journey
e-book and audio book other uh free
things thrown in to make the pre-order
at twenty dollars a super good deal you
can wait till tomorrow and pay more for
the book and get none of the extras
either way is okay with us whatever you
want to do we're good we just want you
to get the book but it's not you know
and paper prices have gone up so book
prices have gone up
who knew who knew we were going to pass
these inflationary costs along to you
everybody that knows economics knew that
so there you go
uh that's how life works so baby steps
millionaires check it out how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth and
how you can too
ramsey solutions.com the pre-order ends
tonight tomorrow is the big day
sacramento is on the line and that would
be sarah calling hi sarah welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i was just curious
my husband and i are blessed that we
have a relatively high income
paying off the mortgage is
obviously a big goal of ours that's our
only debt
and i wondered if
you know given the higher income if we
should consider saving less than 15
percent in our retirement and
other investing and pile more on the
mortgage
probably doesn't matter
because you're probably going to do both
so quickly how big is this big income
well it's i mean relatively big it's
just just under 500 000. that's big
that'll take it
you can't ken you would take it yeah
[Laughter]
all right good for you what do you guys
do for a living
i work in public accounting and he works
for the state he works for the what the
state
for the state oh okay
all right he's he's the governor okay um
in sacramento not great not quite but
close enough okay well we got a great
income good for y'all well done i'm
proud of you
so how much do you owe on the house
we owe about 740.
okay
so the point being if you save 15 of
your income you're gonna pay the house
off in about three years um
or four years if you don't say fifteen
percent of your income you're gonna pay
it off in two or three years
right so it doesn't really matter
you're young how old are you
i'm 36 yeah so i mean before you're 40
the house is paid for and you're
millionaires anyway
well you should be you make a half a
million dollars a year
okay so yeah i mean you're doing great
way to go so i what would i do if i woke
up in your shoes i would put 15 of my
income away
because the years the two or three years
that you're paying this house off you
can't go back and get those and shelter
that income but you can shelter it now
you can dump it into a roth you can dump
it into a traditional
and you keep one way or the other keep
the government's hands off the money and
you can't go back and get those lost
years
and it doesn't affect the timeline of
paying off your house but maybe 12
months
okay okay that makes sense 250 a year
for three years you're done
right
i mean that's the numbers i'm doing just
big math in my head i'm not doing some
kind of complicated formula here but
good lord you all are killing it you're
right you got a big old shovel and it
gives you a lot of options
i would do that just because that way i
can keep that money going in there and
keep the government's hands off of it
that'd be my only motivation is the tax
implications of the investments so
pretty cool yeah i i agree i would do
anything and everything all the time to
keep the government's hands off of my
money there you go there's too much of
the stickies well within reason i mean
i'm not going to go crazy but yeah yeah
we're going that way for sure
good stuff tracy's in north carolina hi
tracy welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys how's it going great what's up
well i feel like y'all are brothers i've
been listening to you for over 20 years
since that free friday wow back in the
day
yes and my baby's now 21 so um and i
just bought your book today so i'm so so
excited cool um
uh you're welcome i have a kind of a
bittersweet um
question a good dilemma bad dilemma sort
of i'm 51 years old and i am in baby
step 7 however it's consequently because
of a divorce
it was
amicable we did not use a lawyer i was
happy with what i got he was happy with
what he got but
what i did was i took my portion and
with that i bought a um
a 300 000 paid for home
and i also put my emergency fund in
place twenty thousand dollars
and i do have three hundred thousand
dollars in my 401k
and so um that that's the kind of
the sweet part um i paid a lot of taxes
but because i've been a stay-at-home mom
for 21 years i do have an education
degree
i now find myself
set up with no debt no payments for the
rest of my life but i'm starting all
over again in my career and i'm scared
and i'm
happy and sad and i can't do my happy
little debt free screen because i didn't
really do it that way and so i'm just
i'm just here i am a baby step seven and
i'm like i i don't even have an encore
career because i really never had a
career hey it's not art it's math
i don't care if it's ugly you're dead
free i'm sorry how you got there too but
you're still there yeah
ugly count
how soon tracy do you have to start
bringing in income
what's your time okay
great question okay so i will be
receiving um right now and i'm saying it
kind of shameful but
this all just recently happened and so
right now i am
i have um i'm living off of what he's
giving me and i will get that for two
more years and that's it's only
40 000 a year but because i don't have
any payments i'm i'm putting a lot away
and i'm living off of that but i really
want to start
working and not have a negative like oh
my gosh negative
work sure oh and i'm very motivated i'm
very ambitious but i'm scared and yeah
all right so hold on a second let's
address the fear first because i think
the fears get you all discombobulated
the fact of the matter is is that you
didn't lose whatever talent or skill you
had the last time you worked 21 years
ago you have all kinds of experience
over that 21 years of of being a
homemaker and everything else that is
also
still there and so you have to
understand that you aren't just this
newbie that's walking in with nothing to
offer that's the first thing i'm just
real quick just we gotta have a very
little bit of time just tell me is there
an idea or two that you've had that that
you at least are interested in trying
knowing you don't have to commit the
rest of your work life to it
yes i would love
honestly i would love to be back in the
classroom but i and i'm not
saying this just because i got you all
on the line but i would love to teach um
your course to children
um middle school um but i i love to get
back in the classroom again but
but what i get afraid thinking of you
know that i'm new at it again
listen tracy listen to me here's the
reality i i don't know the north
carolina numbers but i know the national
numbers we're seeing record numbers of
teachers
that are moving on as well
for for the same reasons that a lot of
other people are moving on in this great
resignation they are looking for talent
all the time to come in the education
system the reality is you have a degree
which means you've got the baseline of
qualifications you need to get out there
and start talking to anybody and
everybody who knows a school board
member a principal these are all your
friends family members you have all
kinds of relationships tracy in
wilmington north carolina you are
qualified at a base level get in the
school system and start working even if
you got to be a receptionist at the
front desk and you make relationships i
don't i know she won't have to but my
point is is i'm opening it up get in the
school system get back in
and then move into it
yep
it's exactly what you need to do
so uh
[Music]
yeah that's the process
and you know in her age she's gonna be
just fine hey thanks for listening yeah
appreciate this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jacob and jessica are
with us hey guys how are you hi
welcome welcome where do you guys live
dictator illinois decatur illinois
awesome good to have you guys
all right how much debt have you paid
off
just over a hundred thousand dollars all
right cool and how long did this take
you
23 months good and your range of income
during that time
it was 100 to 150 good
very cool well way to go guys what kind
of debt was the hundred thousand
it's almost all student loans yeah
what do you what do you guys do for a
living
i'm a speech language pathologist
there's a student loan
and
i also have a degree but i'm a
manufacturing supervisor okay cool
what's your degree in
uh biological sciences ah okay cool
so uh jessica you're using yours yeah
big time big time good degree all right
very well done guys good good so how
long you've been married
two and a half years all right so just
after you get home from the honeymoon
you go
getting out of debt exactly tell us the
story how did you connect up with ramsay
and do all this yes a little bit our
backstory we were high school
sweethearts and in high school
our principal had our senior class go
through financial peace university i
like your principal yeah he yeah it was
awesome i mean that's what planted the
seed and so we got to college and we
didn't i mean we were didn't do it
right but
shortly after we graduated we got
married and as like what you said as
soon as we got home from the honeymoon
it was like we looked at our minimum
payments for our student loans we were
paying a minimum of a thousand dollars a
month yeah just and we'd be
and of course forever if we had our own
bedroom in your house yeah yeah yeah so
you looked at each other newly married
and said we're out of here
and you remembered the ramsey thing back
in the day
okay what'd you do then
budget that was our big thing we just
had a meeting we talked about okay
what do we you drug out the old books or
how did you do it i was listening to
your podcast every day on work okay
yep i gave you the answers though for i
mean because you got to freshen it after
senior year in high school that's a
little cloudy back there yeah yeah and
so you just the two of you sat down and
said okay we're getting rid of this
yep yep we were really really motivated
not
that many people our age do this so it's
kind of hard but we did have a couple
friends i had a mentor she was one of my
supervisors
as an slp and she was going through the
program and just hearing a few other
people rh going through it and the
benefits of you know getting out of it
we just we stuck with it love it yeah
i'm curious about the psychology i think
a lot of young people listen right now
watching this
you knew the principles
and i didn't hear anything where you
thought it was silly it didn't make any
sense but you just went to college you
kind of put off all that adult stuff
right then you guys get married come
back from the honeymoon and hello we see
the first student loan payment now
things are real right is that the
psychology was like oh we have to start
doing this adulting thing and then you
were like okay this made sense back then
we're going to go get into it is that
what happened yeah i think it just made
us
sick to know like we have to pay that
much a month minimum
i mean it's just the there's no freedom
in that yeah and we both don't like
being tied to things and
a lot of each other right yeah yeah yeah
that's good how much do you think the
class helped you realize that it was
doable because you said something
earlier that i think is interesting you
said most people your age couples your
age early 20s
uh maybe mid-20s now but they they don't
normally take this stuff on and you guys
were kind of rare birds which you are
how much you think that knowledge in the
class knowing that you can do it helped
you get even more sick
i think it definitely helped um like she
said planted the seed and so we knew
from going through it the first time
that it was possible and that there was
a proven way of doing it and so once we
plugged back in we're able to just
follow steps and get right to it wow
good for you guys that's good yeah it's
still back there you still you know
it's it's hovering in the back of your
head and it just has to come to the
front yeah yeah very good guys well done
okay when people ask how you get out of
debt you tell them budgeting you said
that what do you think the other keys
are
i think it's weathering the storms i
mean we had two cars break down in the
middle of it i mean it was like 12
months in i think to our debt-free
journey we had two cars break down and
we had been saving for them
um but we could have easily i think been
like oh let's get a nicer car or
all that but um
we didn't we we weathered the storm
life's gonna get you down and you can't
use that as an excuse to make
bad financial decisions
that's right preach it so what what
specifically kept you guys from from
getting a better car i mean when the
rubber met the road there what did you
decide what was the real thing that kept
you in the game the determination to
finish
you had a bigger picture right yeah you
know i don't screw this plan up i'm
finishing wow that's good
very good guys so you said you had
cheerleaders again who were they
cheering you along it was mostly each
other day to day but then we had several
family members my um one of my best
friends now but she was my mentor when i
was in slp her and her husband were
going through it at the same time as us
ah there you go okay yeah nothing like a
mentor that steps back with you and says
go yeah love it very cool well done you
guys your heroes how's it feel to be
free awesome amazing
now you can buy that gum car
right yeah save up and get you a decent
car get out of that hoopty i love it
good for you well done well done we've
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that is the next chapter in your
story for sure go on and be millionaires
and be outrageously generous and be able
to live and change your whole life and
family tree man you got a bright future
ahead of you guys are amazing so good to
meet y'all very very cool and a copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone else and disturb them
the way that class did back in high
school for you i love that story it's
good stuff well done i will have to let
the uh the education solutions team know
that this happened that's absolutely
fabulous jacob and jessica from decatur
illinois a hundred thousand dollars paid
off in 23 months making a hundred to a
hundred and fifty count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three
two one we're debt free
this is how it's done
you know i um
james we need to get uh dave reed's mean
tweets back up again one of these days
because there's some great mean tweets
out there on me
and uh but when we first started doing
that we realized that a percentage of
the mean tweets were
kids in high school
sitting in the high school curriculum
class the foundations class making fun
of the old bald guy on the screen and my
gym teacher's too lazy to teach so he
puts dave ramsey up there right yeah or
whatever that kind of thing and that the
kids just railing on it it's hilarious
and they're so mean it's exactly what i
would have been doing right you would
have been worse oh dave because you and
me together don't have a thought i mean
a.d.d i mean we got it nailed down i
would have had my phone confiscated uh
yeah my phone you know we need to do
going forward this is passing notes they
don't do that anymore they don't have to
no they text they text yeah you know
what we need to do for future editions
in fact we should put this on the docket
folks this is real time hitting dave
with a business idea this could go
sideways quick i think we should film
you
every once in a while just these
break-ins like that you're doing your
normal teaching on the curriculum but
then it cuts away to you going hey stop
saying mean stuff you could be an
algebra you idiot
or you know how you go shut up it's your
classic shut up when you're on stage
like you could be doing push-ups right
now shut up
you know
because it's like why are they so bad
how did you know i was like yeah they're
so angry you can see me
well i was angry i mean you're just well
you're not angry you're just sarcastic
oh just a little punk
and i was a little punk i would have man
i completely would have been trashing me
oh sure if i was in high school and they
put up dave ramsey on the high school
screen yeah and uh but here's what
happens
if you you know if you go through dare
yeah you know remember the old dare
program don't do drugs right thanks to
needy when you go off to college and you
do drugs
then you remember
that there taught you not to do drugs
after that you remember that that's kind
of the same thing right within financial
peace university in school well you're a
good christian i was a good boy i
promise and you know you go through
financial peace university in high
school and then you go off to college
and you get into debt that's it and then
when you get married yeah and you want
to be free you come out and you do your
debt free scream and we still love you
so you put up with the mean tweets for
this kind of exact outcome exactly this
is the outcome i want right here it's
worth it
if you have to go on a circuitous route
to get there you still get there i'm in
this is the ramsey show
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your work your
relationships your money and your
life
this is the ramsay show james is in
portland maine hi james welcome to the
ramsey show
thanks dave i'm calling to get your
opinion on whether to quit my 200 000 a
year remote finance manager job in order
to homeschool my two daughters and work
toward changing my career
i'm 39 and i'm married to a doctor who
makes 300 000 a year
uh we are debt free other than our 380
thousand dollar mortgage on a home worth
approximately 650 000
we have a six-month emergency fund three
hundred and fifty thousand in 401k
amazing 50 000 in college funds so far
wow
how old are you guys
i'm 39 my wife is 34. phenomenal
pretty incredible situation you've
gotten yourself into well done gives you
a lot of choices doesn't it
yeah another wrinkle i wanted to share
is that my wife's specialty has very odd
hours on evenings and weekends
so given my 8 to five schedule we often
end up like ships passing the night so
another feature of this decision
potential decision would be
that i'd get to spend a significant more
you know significantly more time with
her you're eight to five remote
i'm eight to five remote so i work with
people throughout the country um and to
have meetings with them and things like
that i
i work those hours yeah
in finance
yes so finance is in i am a back end
finance uh person for a consulting firm
oh
okay so these are corporate meetings not
consumer meetings i got you okay yes yes
okay cool very cool what would the side
hustle be
uh well that's something i want to
develop i
have a background in you know kind of
creating some content and things like
that so i was
thinking that might be something i want
to do part-time again i don't i it would
be like 15-20 hours a week rather than
a significant amount of time because i
would want to focus on the homeschooling
well number one uh financially you can
just quit
in homeschool right i mean you got 300
000 of your income
and you're just stay-at-home debt right
that's not a problem
uh financially mathematically you can do
that
um but math isn't given isn't what's
giving me a pause here
um
what's giving me a pause is you're going
from working full-time
to not at all
um and i think you have an uh uh
maybe
there's parts of this picture that
you've painted that are more beautiful
than they are
when you start doing it
um
the second thing that it gives me a
little bit of pause
is there's a part of this and
it says you have the ability to bring
200 000 to your family regardless of
what your wife works
or
to
manage that ability poorly
and just quote flip the switch and walk
away today
feels uh irresponsible
there's a part of me that wants to say
that
so i think that that ability to create
that much income that much value for
your family
the transition from that should be
managed very carefully and deliberately
to minimize how much of your earning
potential is lost
and because i'm not positive that 15
hours is actually the actual limit
limiting factor for instance if you were
doing some kind of financial analysis
that you could do
uh when the kids are asleep
or at times that your wife is at work
and the kids are asleep or whatever
where we're not ships passing in the
night where you're not
uh where you work around the homeschool
thing you might still get in 40 hours
pretty easily if you just had a more
flexible environment as an example so i
don't know ken yeah i've got a couple
questions james what's driving this and
there's no wrong answer but what's
driving it is it the kids being
homeschooled
is it you coming home to
uh take a break for a season and get the
benefit of being around the kids and the
wife i mean what's really driving this
the homeschooling is definitely part of
it i mean when we saw that they're
putting kindergartners on ipads we
really didn't like that idea so we moved
to a place that had quote unquote great
schools and then we saw that and
we were not thrilled with that the idea
we were how do you go back to books
after having an ipad it was my question
and so we were really concerned about
that so that was one of the main drivers
the shifts passing tonight's another one
of them and the other is
i went and looked up what the top 10
career was at the time that i was you
know when i was in college and i chose
finance
it isn't necessarily my passion either
so it's kind of i do feel a little bit
like i'm running away
from something
to speak to what you were saying dave
but
at the same time i feel like given the
freedom that i do have should i be
running away towards something that i'd
like to do more the answer is well the
answer is unequivocally yes but what
dave is saying and i agree with dave
let's let's not just bolt right away
let's think of a strategy you know the
idea of a bridge i just like using that
analogy what's the bridge to take me
from where i am to where i want to be
and i think you got three factors here
two of the three
uh by the way all legitimate and and i
just wanted to know what was behind this
because two of the three are family and
relational
and because you've got the financial
wherewithal to do it uh i i'm fine with
it i don't have red flags hearing those
three answers but i do have a red flag
on do you really know
how you're gonna do his homeschool dad
because i think you'll have a more
satisfying
end to this story a more richness of
soul if you find a way to create
something that you earn in the
marketplace that's different than what
you're doing
it may or may not be finance related and
it but it certainly doesn't necessarily
have to be 15 hours
uh there's lots of hours in the week
that um the people do lots of things
that are complete waste of time
um and so i
i i think you will like
your life better yourself better
if you are
somehow being a better steward of your
capacity
and it's not to say being a homeschool
dad is not a good steward of it that's
not what i'm saying i'm just saying
you're jumping from a high performance
situation um
completely out of the nest
and um
i just think you're gonna have more of a
shock more whiplash than you think it's
just you're just asking a couple guys
and we're just we're just talking by the
way we don't think there's anything
neither one of us think there's anything
wrong with your idea no uh or your
ability to do it you have the luxury i
just want you to think through it and go
is there can we slow this down just a
little bit
turn up the heat on
the tren what we're transitioning to not
from yes a little bit and i think you'll
get a better result yeah because with it
the ships in the night thing isn't going
to be resolved either way this is his
wife's got a crazy schedule so if he
he's going to see more of her
apparently with this move but
there's other ways to do the
homeschooling there's other ways to do
that you don't have to be the homeschool
teacher
so i just i would ask you to do more
research look at every angle possible on
how do we accomplish the kids being in
the learning environment that you want
you doing something that you really
really enjoy and getting to spend more
time with the wife don't assume that
this is the only way to do it i think
that's really what we're driving at yeah
but what a wonderful place to be
fantastic hey you've got the heart for
it um and
b the math in the household allows you
to do this and so absolutely on um
on the way you know it's the way to go
no question about it so yeah i just i
there's um
i there's a stewardship thing for me on
everything that that overcoats my whole
life
and so i often look at that and go okay
i have this
ability and i'm supposed to i have this
potential i have this
bandwidth
and am i using that to its fullest
potential
or am i just letting it go dormant and
escaping and i have a tendency to do the
escape thing like everybody else does i
have to stop and think about it but it's
one of the things it's that whole
concept that keeps me working
i don't have to be here that's right
financially but i'm here because uh of i
have the bandwidth i have the ability to
reach a whole bunch of people still
and uh and so i need to do that
i need to do that i'm going to have a
best my best life because i did that's
right that's what i'm looking for hey
good question man love it thank you for
calling in real real brain teaser
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the bugs
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends download the
ramsay network app in your favorite app
store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five ken coleman ramsey
personality best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose is my co-host
today as we talk about your work
your money
your relationships and your life it's
what we do right here on the ramsay show
again open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five danica is
with us in canada hi danica welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken how are you great how can
we help
okay so i just finished funding my three
to six month emergency fund way to go um
i don't thank you i don't have a house
um so i'm gonna start saving for a down
payment but i'm a little unsure because
right now in ontario we have like a
housing affordability crisis
um it's really expensive like
a condo of like one bedroom is maybe
minimum 350 000.
so
i'm torn between
do i like save up a down payment until
just like be patient have enough money
until i can buy something or is it
better to continue renting and then put
that money in an investment
i'm not really sure like where i should
go with that one
how old are you
i'm 35. okay cool
um and how long have you been in in that
city
i've lived um well my whole life pretty
much
okay
all right yeah i live a little for like
an hour away from where i grew up but
um
if i wanted something
more affordable i'd have to move
probably three or four hours away okay
well that's an untenable commute right
definitely yeah we're not we're not
doing that so that's that's off the
table you have to change jobs if you did
that
um and which is a possibility i mean
that's okay if you live in an area you
simply can't afford to buy in ever
then that means you can't afford to live
there you need to be able to buy a home
at some point in your in your process
there's nothing on fire
uh but when you're able to save up a
good down payment and able to make a
purchase i would go ahead and make the
purchase yeah
but it shouldn't take you decades
uh it should be a matter of um you know
you're out of debt you don't have
anything to do except use your income
now to get your emergency fund to save
for your down payment and i just would
do that and then
go ahead and make the purchase and put
down the roots um doubtful that the real
estate's coming down
so um you know you want to do you want
to get in on the ride rather than just
watch other people ride
it's uh you will end up with fomo that's
true you know dave i i hear just a tinge
of
intimidation or maybe i don't know if i
can actually do it and i i just want
danica i just want you to hear me say
the same thing in you that got you out
of debt that got the emergency fund is
going to allow you to put a really nice
down payment down it is doable yeah you
got to be patient yeah and dang it
that's hard isn't it it's really hard
especially when it's a housing thing and
the housing prices seem to go up by the
minute
uh in an area that's expensive already
and that kind of stuff but yeah you'll
just end up taking your time and
shopping around and finding the bargain
and you know you'll you know mark it'll
calm down a little bit in the meantime
and that'll be good for you as well and
you'll get in there you're going to get
in the housing market and
just don't get in over your head and
15-year fixed rate where the payments no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
and you'll be in good shape
joshua's in denver hey joshua what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call i'm a
huge fan it's an honor to speak with you
today you too how can we help
um okay so um i had a car loan in 2017
it was repossessed almost immediately
because i couldn't afford it um my
credit report says that a little over 7
500 was charged off in 2019 i finally
got them on my debt snowball and when i
called they said that they wrote it off
for just over 4 500 and that'll get a
1099 in the mail this february
um the man from wells fargo said that i
don't owe them the debt does the 1099
actually replace the debt or should i be
on the lookout for the other 3 000
popping up somewhere 10.99 hasn't got
anything to do with anything
that's just a collector technique
okay debt that is uh forgiven
is taxable and you're supposed to get a
1099 on it is he saying they are
forgiving the debt if he's saying that
he needs to send you a note that says
that
um he says that i no longer owe wells
fargo that's great send me a note that
says that and did they sell the debt to
someone else
um no i asked them where the debt was um
if they did he's not telling me i asked
him where the debt was he said the only
thing that i'll get is a 1099 with the
45 27 total on it and um
there as far as wells fargo knows that i
don't owe them the debt yeah
well that's
that's absolute hogwash okay okay um it
sounded like it well you're probably
just dealing with a lazy guy on the
other end of the phone now here's what's
happened okay a company can write a debt
off
meaning they give up on collecting it
and they write the bad debt off as a
business expense
at which point they can send you a 1099.
that is a tax
thing
they know they they want to write it off
as a bad debt and take the taxes take
the deduction on the taxes for the bad
debt and they want to send you the 10.99
which means you owe taxes on four
thousand five hundred dollars and that
is all proper and correct that has
nothing to do with whether you still owe
the debt
okay
if they want to forgive the debt
i want them to send me a letter or an
email at least saying
that this account has a zero balance
nothing is owed
so that some [ __ ] later they because
what they'll do is wells fargo is
classically incompetent
they're massive company
and they are full of fools
just full they packed a whole bank full
of them
okay and you got a hold of one of them
so what they'll do is they'll batch all
these bad debts on these repo uh repo
deficits in a package and they'll sell
them to a debt buyer for pennies on the
dollar who will then come and try to
collect from you
and you will go oh no they said i didn't
know it and they say oh well you do owe
it because you don't have any proof in
writing that you don't know it you had
an idiot and a cubicle on the phone tell
you
that you got to get them back on the
phone and get it in writing and you got
to hound them until you get it in
writing if they send it to you in
writing i don't care if it's an email
that this account has been completely
written off you owe nothing we've given
up you have a zero balance there will be
no forward collection attempts
whatever it says along those lines
settled in full whatever forgiven in
full i don't care what they call it but
something along that language you
following me
got it um so i i get that in writing and
then pay the taxes and then it's done
yep
okay awesome but i doubt that's going to
happen
because i think they still have sold
this bad debt to somebody for a nickel
on the dollar who's going to show up on
your doorstep wanting the dadgum money
for the whole thing by the way
but the 10 because the 1099 is not a
legal release from the debt
it's simply them saying we want to write
this off as a bad business expense and
we're gonna put the taxes over on you
that's all it is a tax move
and generally speaking it's also a
collector's move
but yeah you're dealing with wells fargo
god help you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it's book launch week for the baby
steps millionaires book it comes out
officially tomorrow
will be shipped to you and you can order
until midnight tonight at
ramseysolutions.com
and still get all of the goodies thrown
in all the goodies being the audiobook
the e-book the legacy journey audiobook
and e-book and several other items as
well over a hundred dollars worth of
things and the book is only twenty
dollars if you order by midnight tonight
the pre-order will help you get that
done today ramsay solutions dot com hit
the store also while you're there uh
join the uh 100 000 folks
online and the 1500 1600 people in the
auditorium
that will be viewing our
free live stream event called building
wealth in 2022. it will be thursday
night
it is a live stream on thursday
night january the 13th this coming
thursday rachel cruz george campbell and
i are going to be talking about how to
build wealth in the year 2022
we are going to talk about how to look
out for scams i look out for things that
don't work
and how to identify the things that do
work we're going to walk you through the
real story on all the stuff you're
hearing about in the news
all this stuff you're hearing about in
social media
and all these broke people with an
opinion about getting rich
and we're going to talk you through
exactly how to do it this coming
thursday it is a free
live stream
but you need to pre-register go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth and pre-sign and we will make
sure you are hooked up with everything
you need you gotta love it man oh man oh
man building wealth 2022 this thursday
ramsey solutions dot com slash wealth
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal dave today's question comes
from walker in kentucky he writes i'm a
20 year old college junior majoring in
political science i was recently
referred to a logistics brokering
company for a full-time job i completed
the hiring process and was offered a
forty thousand dollar a year job with
options for full benefits and an unkept
commission plan on average employees
make 95 000 annually after two to three
years with the top 20 percent of
employees making a little under double
that i have to choose between school and
this career the obvious choice is to
take the job but i don't want to
disappoint my father by dropping out of
college i don't plan to use my degree if
i were to graduate anyway but i'm
conflicted any advice well a couple
things here number one you don't have to
choose between this job
and finishing your degree i think you
don't have to you've got to looks like a
really good financial opportunity in
front of you
but you don't have to i think what you
got to first
weigh in on is
the conversation with your dad you
clearly want to honor your father
you don't want to disappoint him so this
is a conversation on how important it is
that you
finish college
so as to not disappoint your father
because you know
you could disappoint him by making a
good financial decision or you could
resent him
if
you don't take this opportunity
and go to school and then you resent him
and i really get worried about
resentment
and and so i would sit down with dad and
and i would try to meet in the middle
and if your dad thinks it's important
and you don't want to hurt the
relationship you could finish school and
get your degree online while you're
working full-time i mean we see this
with athletes all the time they'll go
pro and they finish their degree and you
can do the same thing so i think you
have to decide what do i want to do
what do i think is right based on what
my father's expectations are my
relationship with my father and then
i've got a really good financial
opportunity but i think it's a false
narrative that you have to choose
this job and no degree because if the
degree is important to you and your dad
you can finish the degree
yeah
and i think you finished the degree but
you should do it for yourself um yeah i
would rather that than do i don't know i
don't think i think doing things that
are tough
for someone else oh
uh you know when you set goals the goals
need to be your goals not somebody
else's
and right now your dad has a goal for
you to graduate from college you don't
have that as a goal
now is a college degree good thing sure
it's a good thing
is it a ticket to success nope
nope we got a whole bunch of broke
people disillusioned in america right
now because they got degrees in
left-handed puppetry and they owe 200
000 to freaking naviant
and uh they're being abused by their own
government and it's a mess out there
people have you noticed
yeah so you know you don't want to be
joining that mess so don't do this for
your dad but do it for yourself i'm with
ken i think you take the job and you
finish your career finish your degree at
night
and weekends and whatever else and you
figure out another way to do it
we did this okay yeah sharon and i got
married
um we were so broke we couldn't pay
attention i mean we didn't have two
nickels to rub together i got a job
making big money
eighteen thousand dollars a year
fifteen hundred bucks a month big money
to brag dave big money in 1982 just shut
up all right
i was making big money
and they were actually going to pay me
even like no matter what happened as
long as i went to work and stuff oh wow
i've been on straight commission my
whole life i never had a job where they
just oh that is true so i was just i was
so thrilled and none of my buddies even
hardly got jobs that year it was a tough
year in the economy
so i get this job and it's in nashville
so we got to move to nashville well
sharon has like five classes left to
finish her degree oh so
i marry her take her away from the
university to go get a job so we could
eat
and um
her dad
didn't wasn't real thrilled with all
that yeah can you imagine number one i
was involved so yeah i think it was more
than a degree dave but that's okay but i
i to my credit i did promise him i said
uh she will get her degree we've just
got to figure out a way to do it let us
get over to nashville and get landed and
we'll figure it out and we couldn't
figure it out i mean she took a job i
took a job and we never got it back
around to it for about two years three
years so the first baby comes and we get
this idea that sharon's gonna uh work
her degree
now that now that we've got a baby
so we looked at another college locally
to transfer the credits to from
university of tennessee and east
tennessee and couldn't they they
transferred but it would take another
year to finish and it was just showing
this like four classes yeah to graduate
so we figured out she could take the
four classes in summer session in those
little short cram course sessions oh
yeah six weeks long
so she drove to knoxville six weeks in a
row
and stayed with my parents
and
left my baby in a daycare wow and went
to class for
four weeks in a row or six weeks in a
row to finish those four stupid classes
to get that stupid degree but she got it
and we cried she'd leave i'd cry she'd
cry it was awful it was horrible six
weeks right absolutely horrible but we
were 20 something i mean you know
anything right so she comes back she's
got her degree by gotcha but why'd she
do that
really
because it was a good thing to you don't
be that close and not finish
all right i mean four classes come on no
i'm not finished with four classes so
even i got that as dumb as i am you know
and uh and she wanted to do it but but
also i promised her dad it meant a lot
to him that's the point and i made a
promise but i really we weren't doing it
only because not at all we were doing it
because it felt like the right thing to
do and you're that close to the finish
line right and you can pay a price on
the short term here and i'm glad it was
a rough six weeks 40 years ago it's
tough it was rough six weeks and uh uh
but it was worth it and yeah you do that
you you take the night classes you take
some weekends you take some six weeks of
cram courses you take your vacation time
you use it to go to class
and you finish the stinking degree dave
this you and i i don't know that we
agree on this but i was answering the
question to him
personally
once i realized that i wouldn't need the
degree
i wouldn't go back i just have a hard
conversation with my parents and cast
some vision on it but that's not what he
asked i want him to sit with his dad he
needs to determine how big of a deal it
is to make his dad happy i personally on
the issue if college is not the only way
or the best way to do the career you
want then i say forget it but i'm a
little bit out there on that one but
it's also a practical guide i mean
that's my litmus test those two
questions well i think we need to go
more that way than the way we've gone
where all college is good no matter what
it is no matter what it is total
marketing that's just absolute hogwash
yeah same people and that's the way
that's the way the culture is i'm more
on your team yeah um
he can be very successful without a
college degree yes
in his junior year he can finish
his junior year yeah it's okay knock it
out absolutely you can do both it's not
it's not as fatalistic as either or
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks america we're glad you're here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money it
is a free call ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host
chris is with us in albuquerque
albuquerque new mexico hey chris how are
you
hey dave how are you thanks for taking
my call and thank you for fixing stupid
and stupid as me so thank you for that
well we've all been there brother what's
up
yes sir so um a tragedy has put me in a
position to buy a house that i know i
can't afford
with you know
um
20 down with the fourth or a mortgage in
the fourth of my income so right now i'm
21
i make 74 000 a year
next year that'll go up to ninety
thousand
i have eighty thousand dollars saved
um
this house is worth two hundred and
ninety four thousand probably i'll be
buying it for two hundred ninety four
thousand it's worth about four hundred
forty 000
so i'm wondering do i just put down the
20 percent
which is 58 000 or do i kind of go more
aggressive and
wipe out my savings
with why i guess except a thousand
dollars and get my mortgage as low as
possible
i do want to do a 15 year i don't want
to go 30 um
but what do you do for a living
i work
in procurement and pretty much
government contracts for a national
laboratory
okay
i missed the part where a tragedy helped
you i don't understand okay so one night
it didn't help me by no means
my uncle passed away five months ago um
five months ago yesterday
and so
i'm kind of the only one in the position
to buy a house and my my family wants to
keep it in
and by no means of the forest i've been
taking care of the house for a couple
months and i absolutely love it
um
i just don't i don't know so the family
wants to sell you a house that's valued
at 440 for 300.
for yes sir 294. okay where did the 294
come from
that is what my uncle owed on the house
so
that's that's what they're saying before
okay why
because they wanted to stay in the
family that badly
um yes sir is there an obligation on
your part to never sell it
no
is it on family land
it is not unfamiliar i know sir okay
so what happens if you uh get married
and your new wife doesn't want it and
you sell it
is everybody in the family mad at you
that is a possibility however i don't
think so um i think realistically
my mom would actually probably downsize
and get into it um
you know they they're very emotional
they're holding on to just about
everything
had made a comment um can't get into the
house i'll pass yeah this is a trap yep
your families your family your family is
whacked
this is a trap you're 21 years old
this is a trap you're going to regret
this because of all not because of the
math but because of all the emotions
tied to it you're going to get painted
into the corner and you're going to get
paint on your feet somebody's going to
be pissed at you when you try to do
something nice and you strain your butt
off at 21 to do it
well it's my goal so i've been living
here since a month after it taking care
of it and at first you know i felt
pressured but after these couple months
i know you're gonna feel pressure when
you want to sell it and somebody wants
to buy wants to buy it from you at a
deal
well i don't i don't necessarily know if
i want to sell it my goal is to pay it
off no you're going to want to sell it
someday
and when you do somebody's going to be
pissed if you don't give them a deal
inside the family
yes sir there's that expectation on this
there is you know i'm right
no i i i they're gonna bring up the fact
that they gave you a good deal
chris let me ask you this if if your
uncle had not passed away and this house
situation didn't come your way would you
be looking to buy a 294 000 house if
this hadn't happened right now well
when when he passed i was in a totally
different position like i said i was
stupid and then i found i found dave
five months ago i was about sixty
thousand dollars in debt i sold
everything got myself a hoop deep paid
off my student loans
now i'm completely debt free with eighty
thousand who are the uh who are the
heirs
your mom my mom
my mom and her sister okay
uh they have to write you a detailed
letter
that says you are free to do with this
house
anything you want
anytime you want without asking anyone's
permission
you are not obligated to give them first
route of refusal you are not obligated
to give your cousin a deal your cousin's
dog a deal you're not obligated to do
nothing
if you buy this house it is yours to do
with as you dadgum well please forever
and ever and no one is allowed to say a
peep about it that needs to be in a
letter
i agree with that 100
but i think i don't think they can do
that
because you've already got it my mom
will move down into it if i want to move
you've already got all these backup
plans and all these side angled things
and that's what's scaring me here yep
i mean
i say that i mean they they live in a
house all of us have moved out that's
the only reason why she would
but
but they're very emotional people you
just said too
yes you've already let too much escape
out of your mouth to backtrack now no no
yeah i'm not trying to backtrack uh
sure you are you got used to the
pressure you admitted you got used to
the pressure initially there was
pressure and i don't think you would
have been in the market for a house this
expensive at this age you're 21 you're
in great shape
here's the here's the way i want this
laid out if you keep it a year and sell
it and make 500 000 profit nobody says
beep
yes and if that is the case
then do the deal
then do the deal yeah yeah you can do
the deal put everything down but an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses not everything but a thousand
dollars so everything but everything but
fifteen thousand dollars and then if you
get in trouble do not hang on to this
house in the name of family emotion you
sell it
just sir sell it
if you get in trouble it's a stupid
house
is it an issue going 15 years because no
put it on a 15-year fixed rate put down
65 000 keep 15 000 in your account but
you and your mama and your aunt all
better be emotionally prepared to cut
this thing loose because you are getting
into an emotional trap and i'm afraid
the trap is going to destroy you not the
deal
okay you hear my concern loud and clear
no i do and i i
i thought about that and that that is an
issue yeah i mean the number of times
man in 30 years that i have talked to
wonderful people like you and your mom
where your aunt gets so pissed off she
can't breathe because jim bob her third
cousin didn't get a deal on the house
after she gave you a deal on the house
and it was an unwritten set of
assumptions and you know what an
assumption makes everybody
that's what happens and you got to have
you got to have real clear on that in
writing it's not a legal binding
contract but it's them saying out loud
you are free to sell this house 20
minutes after you buy it and make a
profit and nobody gonna say beep
and chris chris you don't have that
freedom yourself emotionally and they
won't give it to you emotionally
relationally please yes walk that's
right
because chris needs a you need to
emotionally prepare yourself that you're
not going to get this letter i'm with
dave if i was i don't think they can do
it i don't think they can either i don't
think you're going to get the letter so
you got to be prepared for that yeah i
think because i think they're going to
want to hold it over your head this is a
game these people play man and it's just
i can smell it
man there's crazy in every family and it
takes all kinds of different forms be
careful
and i'm not saying your mama's crazy i
didn't call your mama crazy don't get
mad at me
but i said it could be
could be the ant it could be jim bob and
it could be jim bob's blue tick hound i
don't know but somebody in that pile is
going to cause a mess i'm just saying
and i'm just man i've spent so much time
in rooms with people that everybody's
mad and
it has nothing to do with the financial
transaction it has everything to do
there by a set of assumptions
and that's a real
you're 21 man you got a big wonderful
life ahead of you
don't screw it up with your uncle's
house
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 15 29 the
lord is far from the wicked but he hears
the prayers of the righteous
abraham lincoln says nearly all men can
stand adversity but if you want to test
a man's character give him power
well that's true
give him money give him power yeah so
those are two things that
expand magnify what is already there
anthony's with us in san antonio hey
anthony welcome to the ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen thank you for
taking my call um
currently actually sitting in a bit of a
predicament
wondering if it's really a good idea to
sell our home in order to pay off debt
uh do you like the house
we do
yeah we do like it um what's the problem
how much debt have you got
well
everything without the house obviously
uh about 115 000. what do you make of
your household income
household is about 120. okay what is
what kind of debt is the 115 what's it
on
uh two vehicles what are they how much
are they
um my truck is about 34
and my wife's vehicle is about 20
22 i think
okay and you oh what on the house
uh 215. okay and what's it worth
um
in this market currently i'm probably
anywhere between 330 and 360. okay
all right
so it doesn't even get you completely
out of debt
not completely um
depending on how i depending on how i
sell it yes how long have you been
working to get out of debt
oh gosh
probably only about a few months now i
thought he started listening to you a
few months ago cool how much have you
paid off so far
uh
about
was about probably about four
yeah four thousand dollars and how many
months
probably
uh probably about six weeks two months
at the most
okay all right well that sucks
yes
yeah you're not making much progress
no okay
is that the reason the fact you kind of
are uh kind of stopped up here that
you're thinking of selling the house
yeah we're
we're living paycheck to paycheck um and
have been for for probably at least a
year now um just keeping yourself with
the debt
okay uh the idea what's your why what's
your wife saying about all this
she's on board i'm bored with what
we're selling the house and uh
paying off debt and then
spending another
couple of years just kind of saving up
and so you're having a pretty good
discussion about the money problems then
without without trying to kill each
other
good good that's good that's a good
basis to move forward that's for sure
um
well the way i answer questions on this
show is what i would do
unless you don't like the house and you
said you do like it um
then moving is very expensive
emotionally financially
disruptive to everything else in your
life it takes up bandwidth it's
exhausting i'd rather have a root canal
um you know moving is just a pain in the
butt and so
i'll sell almost anything pretty quick
when we start to get out of that process
but the house unless you don't like it
anyway is something i sell i suggest you
sell very slowly so if i were in your
shoes what i would do i'm going to put
you guys into ramsey plus for a year i'm
going to pay for it and let you get into
financial peace university and i want
you to start working the system hard
no eating out unless you're you don't
need to see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there no more
vacations no more nothing
beans and rice rice and beans you are
broke people that make 120 000 a year
and you need to start acting like broke
people and you haven't been i know
because you suck at how much debt you've
paid off you haven't made any progress
because you've not had any intensity yet
you need to crank up the intensity about
17 notches
i think before i sold my house i'd sell
these two cars yeah i'd love to know
dave i'm getting rid of both cars how
much is the truck worth no it's worth
more than 34. it has to be
in today's yeah i could probably i could
probably walk away with about a thousand
dollars right yeah i'd go buy me a car
with that or a truck with that and i'd
get rid i get rid of both these car
payments before i got rid of my house
yeah you can repurchase and trade cars a
whole lot cheaper and easier than you
can houses and there's some margin by
the way to start budgeting with yeah
you dumped 50 000 you dumped half the
dadgum debt yeah and so i'm selling both
cars and i'm going to work my butt off
on a beans and rice scorched earth plan
for six months and i'll bet you you
don't need to sell your house then i
agree now's the time to sell those used
cars yeah you talk about taking some
stress off of you good time to sell the
house too but yeah i'd sell cars for us
old house i agree with that uh and you
can get another car it's a stupid car
and a stupid house too you can get
another stupid house but
everything's less emotional everything's
stupid today but it's just you don't you
know you don't have to move yeah i agree
you know you just you just get the stuff
out of the glove box that's all you got
to do this is a massive move selling
those cars you're talking about 50
000
yeah i mean i'd list those things
tonight 56 000 bucks out of 115. it is
half
that gum it is half yeah and then let's
just look at the monthly there i mean if
they're carrying seven hundred dollars
seven fifty no that's eight hundred a
month about twelve hundred bucks twelve
hundred bucks oh exactly i can't compute
that dave yeah twelve hundred bucks easy
easy okay well there's your margin that
taking the stress level down and then
just knock the rest out knock the snot
out of that other 56 000 making 120
you're debt-free in 18 months yeah and
you're sitting there with no payment in
the world in 18 months and you save up
very quickly and pay cash for a car
ta-da yeah
and it's just it's just a truck man
really yeah i i like my truck but it i
don't i don't like it more in the house
i don't like it more moving
you know that's the truth
yeah just
i love that you pointed that out now
it's not just the expense
uh the financial expense it's bandwidth
the nesting that takes place at the wife
i know she's on board but that's a major
disruption and not necessary in this
case figuring out where to put the
dishes oh my god all right miguel is
with us miguel is in reading
pennsylvania miguel i'm short on time
uh give us a quick question
hey dave um uh
so i'm a full-time uber driver and i'm
just calling because from a moral
perspective
i've been tracking my own miles uh
outside of what the uber uh tells me i'm
driving when i'm online and because i
drive about an hour away
for tax purposes it ends up breaking
even
um uh
this isn't a problem for this past year
it's going to be a problem for next tax
year when i'm actually starting um start
investing for retirement so breaking
even i mean you're my the miles you
compute and the miles the app computes
are breaking are the same is that what
you mean by breaking even
uh yes with the the standard uh mile
deduction from the irs okay okay
well i mean either one then is fine to
use you just gotta be able to prove it
in the event of an audit and you have to
feel morally correct about it and you're
telling me it's the same number so why
wouldn't it be
uh well basically uh when i say breaking
even that means uh there's there's no
profit when i wrote oh that's what i
asked i asked if you had the same number
of miles with your calculation uber's
calculation and you said oh no yes it's
not what you meant by you mean you're
not making any money driving uber
yeah uh that's uh according to if i
track my own miles uh because it doesn't
include the ubered app doesn't include
the actual miles that i drive guess
right that means you're not making any
money that's what that means
really because the irs didn't come up
with that i mean they're not very good a
lot of things but that mileage number is
fairly accurate it's costing you that
what the irs is allowing you to deduct
that's a real cost it's a cost in lost
value in the car it's a cost in extra
maintenance on the car it's a cost in
fuel on the car wear and tear on the car
that's where mileage deduction comes
from
and so you really are having those real
expenses so you really are really
breaking even it's not necessarily
breaking even the cash out of your
pocket because you haven't had to buy
tires yet because you wore them out but
when you put the tires back in and
change the oil and the repairs that are
adding to it with the wear and tear on
the car and the lost value when you get
ready to sell the car you really are
breaking even because you're driving too
far in and your uber deal's not making
sense so probably need to find something
else to do but practically speaking on
his question you should accurately log
all those miles yeah uber's giving you
one number but if you can prove the
other mileage yes you should do that you
need to yeah yeah assuming the code
allows you to book driving in to start
driving yeah which is what you're saying
and i'm not sure it does but if i don't
know what the irs code allows but either
way the bottom line is is you're
spending that money and you're breaking
even
uh really not just in taxes
so what's that hour in the books thanks
king coleman thank you sir thanks to
james childs and kelly in the booth i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
a friend or family member that needs a
daily dose of ramsay advice in their
life let them know about the ramsey call
of the day podcast it's a quick hit of
advice about life and money in under 10
minutes check out the ramsey call of the
day podcast wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you